What's up, man? Are you uh LDS? Are you
Muslim? I'm LDS. LDS. Awesome. How long
you been here? Did you see uh Eric's
argument laid out? No, I missed most of
that,
but I'm just enjoying the conversation.
Yeah, that other one was a little off
topic. I apologize. Um, hey, so I'm
going to I'm going to try to convert you
to Islam. Are you ready to hear an
amazing proof for the prophethood of of
Muhammad? I let me just stop you right
there. I am probably on the same page as
y'all that uh Islam's just as
uncompelling to me as it is to y'all. By
the way, wait till you hear this proof
though. Sure. Okay, just play along.
Just just just bear with me. Bear with
me. All right. So, there's a prophecy in
Sarah 61:6. I'm going to read it. This
is the Saki International. Uh it says,
"And mentioned when Jesus, the son of
Mary, said, "Oh children of Israel, I am
indeed the messenger of Allah. to you
confirming that which came before me in
the Torah and bringing good tidings of a
messenger to come after me whose name is
Akmad. But when they came to him with
clear evidence, they said, "This is
obvious magic." And so according to
Muhammad, Jesus prophesied his coming.
Do you see any problems with that? I
mean, I don't believe Muhammad in this
instance for sure. Well, why would you
why would you not believe him? He said
Jesus prophesied his coming. Yeah,
that's okay. Everyone can do that. But
uh there has to be some sort of uh
evidence confirmation like external
confirmation. Well uh it doesn't have to
be just external. I I don't think
reality is just externally uh perceived.
I would say that it's also internally
there's I I don't think it's just
outside forces I'd say. Okay. So would
you find it sketchy that Muhammad Do do
you know of anywhere that this prophecy
is found? Have you read the New
Testament? Of course. Yeah. And so, do
you know what prophecy he could be
referring to? Obviously, Muhammad is now
mentioned in either Old Testament, New
Testament. Good job. But it seems like
you're leading me somewhere. I am
leading you somewhere. I'm leading you
somewhere. So, um, no, better be Wendy's
is all I'm saying. No sh We got Shake
Logic. He's going to cook for us. We
don't We don't need to go out. Okay. So,
I'm in. Um, and so yeah, you would say
it would be weird for a prophet to say,
"Nobody knows about this particular
prophecy about me, but trust me, guys,
Jesus really did predict my coming."
Would you find that to be very sketchy?
Uh, not in the absolute. I mean, all uh
would it be a red flag? No, not
necessarily. Not necessarily. There
wouldn't be a red flag. Let me explain.
What I'm thinking is uh everything in
the Old Testament, we believe that uh
I'll say Yahweh, Elohim, God of the Old
Testament, he started somewhere. Whether
that's Abraham or if we go back to
Melzdic or Enoch, God started somewhere.
There was a first theophony. And whether
that's Adam or whoever you want to say,
like there was a start of the pattern.
And like y'all were saying with the
other LDS guy, there's prophetic
patterns and I'm all for that. But like
God speaking to someone new would not be
a red flag to me. But uh obviously God
has spoken. Sure. So but you wouldn't
think like wouldn't it be the worst
possible choice if there was a prophecy
say you're a prophet and somebody
foretold you're coming and God's looking
out. He's going to pick somebody.
There's a first of all somehow the
prophecy gets lost. That's bad. That's
strike one, right? There's a prophecy
about this particular prophet and it
just somehow gets lost. So, strike one,
for some reason, something happens. God
allows this prophecy to be lost. But
then he's going to re-reveal the
prophecy. And he's going to reveal the
prophecy through the very prophet that
it's about. You wouldn't find the fact
that Muhammad does this, not not even
one bit, to be sketchy, like weird, like
kind of proof of fraud that he's kind of
like, you know, writing his own job
reference or giving himself, you know, a
pat on the back a fivestar review. I
mean, uh, I don't know how much we want
to rehash the last LDS guys,
uh, just prophecy conversation, but what
I would say is Oh, sorry. Sorry. I
didn't I didn't start here, so I didn't
know the initial. You're good. But uh
what I would say is that at least from
what you quoted, I'm not familiar with
the Quran uh to any meaningful degree,
is that uh it doesn't seem like that
passage is
um trying even to connect itself to the
Old Testament, the New Testament when
and you won't agree with this and that's
okay. Some LDS will typically um tie not
Joseph Smith specifically, but like the
Book of Mormon, let's say, or just
continuing Revelation to Isaiah 29, to
Ezekiel 37. Now, that might not be
compelling, but but my point is, at
least with Islam, is that we are trying
to tie it back to the Old Testament. I
would say that's a step up. If it's not
at all, that's totally I think I think
Avery and I will both say that Muslims
try to do the exact same thing with
Deuteronomy 18, Deuteronomy 13,
laughably Song of Solomon 5, laughably
John 14. It's weird to look for
prophecies in the Song of Solomon's
regardless in my opinion, but I we can
agree upon that. Thank you. Can you say
that again, Levi, for the Muslims that
are watching? I just I don't know the
New Testament quoting from the Song of
Solomon's in any prophetic degree
either. So like feels like a weird text
to So So here's what I'm here's what I'm
trying to say. Um Muhammad, this this
should be a red flag. This is a huge red
flag to me. I don't For one, it's it's
asking me to reason in a circle. In
order to believe in the prophecy, I got
to believe in the prophet. But in order
to believe in the prophet, I got to
believe in the prophecy. That's
viciously circular. The second problem
is God is not a a doofus. He's not going
to allow a prophecy to get lost about a
fortold prophet and then if if he does,
he's not going to reveal it through that
prophet. He's going to give us ways to
externally verify. So you and I both
believe to to some extent we believe
different things about Jesus, but we
believe that like Isaiah 53 for or or
Psalm 22 or uh Zechariah uh chapter 9
and and and different things are
referring to Jesus, right? And so and
those to us seem pretty clear and we can
actually go back. The Jews had these
books, right? like we have the great
Isaiah scroll uh in the in the Dead Sea
Scrolls that the very people who were
opposing us had these scrolls in their
possessions, right? So, we can check
these, but we can't check Muhammad here.
And the problem is is as you're probably
aware that Joseph Smith does the exact
same thing in Genesis 50:33 in 2 Nephi
3:15. He
self-certifies, which to me that ought
to raise like a huge huge huge red flag
that like why would you do that? It
doesn't make any sense. Why would God
pick that person to reveal that
prophecy? And so you have to say either
God's really kind of stupid and he wants
us to reason in circles and he can't
preserve a prophecy and he can't give us
a way to verify it and check it. We just
have a trust me bro. I would or it
should like to me this should make you
it would make me uncomfortable if Jesus
did this. If Paul did this, if Paul was
like I you know a great light will come
uh to to the Gentiles and it will start
in in uh Damascus and and spread all the
way to Rome and it's in Isaiah 67. I'd
be like, "Oh, there's something funny
about the Apostle Paul." You've said
Isaiah 67 twice tonight. Um Isaiah
doesn't exist. Okay. It doesn't exist.
That's the point. Just like Genesis,
Genesis stops in in every New Testament
that we have or excuse me, I said New
Testament, Old Testament that we have.
Genesis stops in verse 26. But Smith in
the Joseph Smith translation extends it
all the way out. Let me show it to you.
A, if you want to put that back, the
screen back up real quick. This is the
Joseph Smith translation. He says, "And
that seer I will bless, and they will
seek to destroy him. For those that seek
to destroy him shall be confounded, for
this promise I give to you, for I will
remember you from generation to
generation, and his name will be called
Joseph. And he shall be after the name
of his father." We know that Smith was a
junior. His father was senior. And this
is Joseph speaking. This is Joseph in
Egypt, that patriarch Joseph, right?
Sure. Um, and so Jacob's son. And so he
takes a page right out of Muhammad's
playbook. So I'm just asking like does
that in any way bother you or make you
like think like that's at least weird?
Because I've I've even gone on like
Mormon forums and there people are
typing in the forums like uh this is
weird. I have questions. This makes me
doubt. And so like if you're honest like
for me I would just say this would make
me doubt. So anyway and that's okay. Um,
I I don't think every ounce of, let's
say, Mormonism is as compelling as
everything else. I think uh Joseph Smith
reading himself in a scriptural text is
less valuable to me than other
theological um propositions. But let me
let me uh I can't remember last LDS
guy's name. I wish I quit referring him
to just other LDS guy. But I think I
disagree with you earlier when you said
this doesn't happen in the New Testament
cuz I would think Luke 4:21 is a good
example of if not Jesus Christ reading
himself into the text cuz the English
word Jesus is nowhere in the Old
Testament of course that'd be anistic
and just like Joseph Joseph literally
with the letter J that sound didn't
exist in the Hebrew times. So of course
Joseph of Egypt isn't Let's pull up Luke
then. Let's pull up Luke. Sure. So Luke
chapter 4. Yeah. Luke start verse 18.
Yeah. Verse
1821 quotes Isaiah 61. Who? Isaiah 1.
Did you hear yourself though? He's
quoting a different prophet. Sure. He's
quoting Jesus is saying that this is me
or this day is this fulfilled in your
ears. And they can they can verify that
because they can look at I don't know
how you could verify that. I mean you
can verify that it's I say I agree. they
can verify the fact that it's in Isaiah.
That's the point. And I hear I see your
point. He's he's not saying like, okay,
Isaiah said that there would become a a
great light and his name shall be Jesus
and he will um save people from their
sins. And this is in you know, I don't
know. Yeah. You know, we might as well.
Um and so he's not doing that. He's
quoting a prophet. Sure. that they can
actually verify. He's also providing
them other evidence through his
miracles. And oh, that's true. I I I I
skipped I skipped a dinner. Well, no, I
had a little bit. But anyways, he's
quoting a prophet. That's the pattern of
a prophet, right? So actually, Levi,
what what what that shows you, Levi, is
that like when he's trying to appeal to
prophecies about his ministry, he's
appealing to public information that
they can check. Uh let me I would say,
and I I had to this is how I'd
articulate it is you're right that
there's let's break up LDS prophecies
into two categories. ones that are
scripturally uh appealed to and others
that are just let's say Joseph Smith
Joseph Smith wrote himself in the texts.
At least on the side of appeal to texts,
I would say Ezekiel 37 is a very popular
LDS. And I'm sure you may have sound
like you've ran into LDS missionaries
before, but I'd say Ezekiel 37 is an
example of LDS being, hey, the stick of
Judah and the stick of uh now I'm
drawing a
blank will be combined together. I'll be
honest, that's about as as convincing to
me as a Muslim coming up to me and
saying Muhammad is in Deuteronomy 18.
And that's okay. I don't expect you to
agree with me. Well, well, right.
Because it's just it's there's they use
vagueness. Second of all, they're just
factually incorrect. But that's too too
vague of a situation, right? Um, sure,
that gives us something to check, but I
just don't know how how one would
interpret that to read it that way. When
I read Ezekiel 37, it's like the valley
of the dry bones and like him, I guess
you would say, that's reviving his
church and that's the dry bones and all
that other kind of stuff. And so I I
think that's referring to in the context
it's referring to reviving Israel.
They're going to go into captivity and
they're going to be brought back and
he's Israel will be restored. And then
ultimately I think it's pointing to the
future and it's pointing to
resurrection. So I get that's better. I
will I will say to you this to you Levi
that that's that's better um than than
appealing to that. But the very fact
that your prophet does that, the very
fact that your prophet does that to
begin with, he doesn't go, "Hey guys,
look, I'm in Isaiah 30 or Ezekiel 37."
He doesn't appeal to that. Later
Mormons, no, during his life, that was
appeal. During his life, he did. Okay,
that's fine. In uh it is in the Book of
Mormon that uh they interpret all kinds
of Old Testament things and they read it
into to what Yeah, we're a little wacky.
Well, I appreciate you the admission
there. No, it's all right. It's all
right. Um, but I would say for for me
this would be a huge red flag. The very
fact, could you imagine him looking, you
know, at the stone in the hat and whoa,
whoa, whoa, I have a revelation. Joseph
saw me all the way back in Egypt and he
even called me by name and even called
me by my my daddy's name. Like, he
called out my daddy's name and I'm the
one. Like, to me, again, I cannot get
around the fact that that's just a
really dumb thing for God to do. He
would at least preserve that particular
prophecy from Joseph so that we could
verify it. Just like I would also go to
a Muslim, and I think you should too. If
you're talking to a Muslim friend, you
should say, "Dude, what's up with this?
Why is Muhammad putting words in Jesus's
mouth to talk about how he's he's
coming? I can't find that anywhere. I
can't verify that anywhere." If I came
to you and I said, "Hey," or if I came
to a Muslim and I said, "I'm in the
Quran. I'm I'm in Surah 7210, you know,
there there's there will be, you know,
and he's going to come from the the
foreign lands and he will testify and
the and the the doubters will be shaken
by his words, right? And and and Avery's
in there, too. The the chef lug efiri
will will
cook, you know, and and then what will
happen though? That's the question,
right? Right. Right. That's that is a
good question. But they're going to all
every Muslim is going to go, "Dude, the
surah stopped four verses ago." And I I
could just go, "But yeah, it was lost."
Uh, you know, um man, those one of the
things that he burned up. He didn't he
didn't want Muhammad to be or he wanted
Muhammad to be the seal of the prophets.
He didn't want to to people to know that
I'm coming and I'm going to set things
right and set things back in order and
restore the tr the the real true faith.
Do you see the problem? I'm listening.
Um I just I guess uh when it comes to
and I didn't know this coming into this
that uh that the discussion tonight was
prophecy. Prophecy is at least in this
regards Muslim versus Mormon is less
interesting to me. But I'm I I I
listening and I'm enjoying your
thoughts. I just think that obviously
like let's say we got Alex Okconor on
here and you're making the appeal and
I'd agree with your appeals that Jesus
is being referred to in uh Old Testament
scriptures, but Alex Okconor might say,
"Well, why should I have that reading?"
Obviously, you and Levi, we think those
are referring to Jesus, but why do I
necessarily
believe that when other Jewish messiahs
were in the neck of the woods? Well,
that would be pretty easy. Well, one of
them is a suffering servant who actually
is pierced for the transgressions of
people and is bor is and I agree with
that. I think that's a good evidence is
buried in a rich man's tomb. And what
Alex would probably be pushed back at
was just like, no, the the servant he's
referring to is referring to Israel. And
I would say, okay, then how is Israel
bearing the transgressions for Israel
and how is Israel being buried in a rich
man's tomb? That's a matter of
interpretation that we could actually
look at a publicly available prophecy
that has been uh preserved for thousands
of years. But what you have right here
is a phantom prophecy that cannot be
publicly verified and you only have
Joseph Smith's word for it just like you
only have Muhammad's word for it. And
so, you know, may maybe there's we're at
a a point where it's like where do we go
from here? But I would just say like
just think about it. I just if anything,
you know, I want to put a pebble in your
shoe and because if it better be a sear
stone. That's all I'm saying. Yeah,
there you go. If Smith would do that,
like what else could he possibly be
wrong about, you know, or or or what are
other things could be sketchy? And so it
I'm not saying this has to like unravel
your Mormonism right here, right now. I
don't I don't expect you to to to just
deconvert right now. But I would ask you
to like think about it and hear the
other side of what people say against
Mormonism because like this is the this
ought to make you uncomfortable. I just
a little background about me. I did
serve an alias mission which does make
me like a cosmic authority, don't get me
wrong, but like I I've I've had
conversations before and I enjoy them. I
think talk me all and I'm not sure what
your uh
denominational persuasion is, but uh I
mean I'm all for conversation. I think
that's how we stop talking past each
other. And like these concerns of yours
I think are totally valid. Mormonism is
pretty wacky and I think it goes beyond
the prompt tonight, but I think there's
some compelling parts that are not the
conversation tonight. But but maybe
maybe next time y'all host I'll have to
hop back in. Yeah. And I think there's
compelling parts for for the case for
Christianity and and and maybe those
those are always things you can find on
my channel and I'll be doing other lives
and I I like talking to you. Um so if
you ever I I'll probably do some stuff
on just New Testament reliability or
stuff like that, which isn't necessarily
something we would totally disagree
with, but you know, you know, feel free
to to hop on on any of those if I bring
it up for for invitations and stuff like
that. But yeah, but just think just
think about it. Sure. Cuz again, if he
would say this, like that's kind of
weird, you know, what what else what
what are the other holes in the in the
story? So, and I think that's fair. If I
can make one more point, I would say
that maybe uh sometimes LDS will say
mainstream Christianity in distinction
to Mormonism. I don't know if that's
ever like offensive, but I guess that's
what I'm rolling with. I would say that
there is a level of prophetic uh
skepticism towards Mormonism and maybe
fairly so that uh atheists have been
doing the last 2,000 years to uh
Christianity and maybe even earlier
Canaanites and friends doing to Judaism
and Israelite religion that uh I think
maybe we need to approach it more on an
individual base by base basis rather
than would I be offended if God spoke to
someone new today a big selling LDS test
point. No, they would just, and I think
we'd agree on this, they would need some
strong strong strong evidence. If God's
dropping a sequel, there has to be some
confirming evidence, not confirming
evidence. I think Mormonism meets some
of that, at least enough to be
compelling to me, but I totally get that
it's not compelling to other people.
Sure. Yeah. I mean, again, there'll be a
whole other topic to evidence. I don't
know. Joseph's visions versus versus the
resurrection and different things like
that. Uh, a good book I'd recommend and
we could let you go. Uh, Rob Bowman has
a really good book on that very topic.
Jesus's visions uh versus uh the
resurrection. Um, you might totally
disagree with him, but you know, I it
would be interesting. I'm sure he would.
It would be like a book that I would
recommend cuz I'm a very staunch
evidentialist. And so, check check that
out. Real quick, is your YouTube channel
Eric Testify? I've only heard of God
logic since the OKConor debate,
honestly, which is funny that an atheist
is introducing me to other Christians.
To be fair, I think God Logic and Alex
Okconor and David are all interesting.
But is your is your channel Eric Testify
or Okay. Okay. Yeah, Testify. Testify
apologetics. You can find me there.
Cool. Well, it was nice talking to you
all. Yeah, you too, man. You too. Take
care. You too. See you guys.